the problem that we have now is that our
technological capability has overtaken
our wisdom we have the ability to
release viruses and cause damage at the
moment we have the ability to cause them
but not really the ability to protect
ourselves from them right now the job of
humanity is to ensure the future of
humanity like some of the smartest
people that I know don't think that
humanity is going to make it past 2100.
some of the smartest people that I know
think why what do they think is the
biggest threat all right guys bang bang
I've got Chris here with me uh I thought
a great topic to start out with would be
reinvention I think you and I both uh
we've had like multiple lives maybe not
nine like a cat but multiple lives
um walk me through like how you've
thought about Reinventing yourself
multiple times is it intentional or does
it kind of just happen are you following
your interest what's going on yeah good
point so uh I do a podcast now and for a
long time I was a nightclub promoter and
in between that I did reality TV so I
guess I've done a few different
iterations or whatever of being me and
um yeah I think the what you end up
doing is outgrowing whatever it is that
you do now and whatever you think you're
calling is kind of like a crab inside of
a shell and then it gets uncomfortable
and you start to notice that things
don't feel too right and then you end up
having to get rid of that so my journey
was go to UNI start a business running
nightlife have a great time I'm a young
20 year old guy like running nightclubs
and everybody knows my name and I'm on
the front door and stuff like that but
then
toward the end of your 20s I think a lot
of guys encounter what I call the manual
pause which is this sort of situation
where you realize all of the values and
things that you used to look up to in
other people aren't going to serve you
anymore and they don't serve you and for
me like
getting drunk and going out and having
fun and stuff was fantastic at 21 but at
29 30 I think is this really all that
I've got to offer the world is this you
know going out and partying with the
boys on the weekend is that really what
I'm gonna like max out life at so I had
to let go of some of those things and
one of the problems that you see is some
people aren't prepared to let go of that
because they're scared of whatever's on
the other side of it or maybe they don't
have any role models around them or any
support in their friend groups that
allow them to go on and do that so for
me I had to the the pandemic was a
really good thing it was terrible for a
lot of people but it was great for
forcing a change in my life because it
shut down all nightclubs basically for
two years so I had to learn that I could
exist without that what is it like to
not be the business owner I was before
and another big part of it and it may be
the same with you is letting go of the
identity that you used to be like who am
I if I'm not
X if I'm not the investor if I'm not the
podcaster the club promoter the reality
TV guy who am I then is that something
that you notice with yourself as well
yeah and I like the framing of it's
outgrowing who you were rather than like
a U-turn or like uh a hard right it's
you're still the same person you're
almost just kind of expanding whether
it's your ambition your interest or
whatever and if you're out growing
something that I think insinuates
Improvement or or like kind of moving
forward
um but it also means that like you're
building on top of the things that you
previously learned or experienced so
like a nightclub uh while they probably
have some negative connotations in some
circles I think there's also a lot of
people who say to themselves you
probably learned a hell of a lot about
human psychology about business about
negotiating about uh memetic desire like
talk a little bit about that experience
and like what exactly do you extract you
know in hindsight from running
nightclubs okay and now you can actually
use in the world biggest learnings the
almanac of running Nikon herbs um one of
the biggest things especially for
business people is the usefulness of
anticipation when it comes to launching
a product or doing anything else so
what's interesting about nightlife
especially in Newcastle the northeast of
the UK these clubs weren't like what
you've got here in Miami huge super
clubs that have got very distinct
identities they were all basically rooms
where people could get drunk to music
like you can dress it up however you
want you can call it whatever you want
this one can have pink branding and this
one can give away free shots and this
one can have r b music and this one can
have house music but basically it's the
same product so all that you're really
competing on is the marketing and the
hype and what we realized was that if we
created a very protracted drawn out
launch sequence it got people really
bought in and I came to realize or
believe that a lot of people don't have
all that much to look forward to
especially if you're young 18 to 23 you
can't afford to go and do the things
maybe that you want to do so you look
forward to the next Jake Paul fight
right you look forwards to the next
release of Game of Thrones or whatever
it is because that's a big part of your
existence what you need to try and do as
a business is inject yourself into that
so there's a study done where they got
people to self-rate their level of
happiness throughout entire night out
and the happiest point of the entire
night was getting ready with their
friends at about 7pm so friends would
come over and they had some music on and
the girls were doing the makeup but the
boys were playing drinking games or
whatever why well it's
often as humans our anticipation of the
event is actually more enjoyable than
the event itself so we tried to Port
this across into business and the way we
did that was that if we were to release
a new event that we had coming up soon
we would announce something big coming
soon like more details this Sunday and
then we might release the day of the
week or or the venue that we were
working in and then we would release a
teaser and then we would release a full
trailer and then we'd release the launch
date with tickets drawing that out
allows you to give something it extends
the anticipation and the enjoyment of
that experience and it really brings
people into the narrative so I was like
that's that was cool and I now do this
with modern wisdom my podcast if I've
got a big guest I have a couple of big
guests coming up my audience will hear
about it a month before it happens I'll
be like I've got someone big coming
here's the person that's coming here's
what I'm recording here's some shots
from behind the scenes here's when it's
going to be released here's a countdown
to when it's released like that's just
me bringing them along for the ride I'm
in it already and so that that's
definitely one big takeaway I mean
there's a ton of other interesting [ __ ]
like watching men fight outside of
nightclubs is [ __ ] fascinating wow
because it's called the male monkey
dance and there's usually a bunch of
different steps I can actually take you
through them so what you see when you
look at particularly male aggression uh
under uh how would you say like less
encumbered circumstances I.E that their
front brain isn't working quite so much
uh so male monkey dance first off you
start with eye contact and a hard stair
what you're doing there is you're
actually sizing up your opponent like do
I actually want to even begin
confronting this person you see this in
animals as well that they'll see each
other and they'll begin to move but they
won't actually do anything that's too
confrontational the hard stairs enough
verbal challenge so like what are you
looking at that will always come next
what you're trying to do there uh male
vocal tone is a massive indicator of
formidability so one of the biggest
things that you have your vocal box
grows as you grow taller so what you're
looking for deeper voices are perceived
as being more formidable and more
intimidating So when you say what are
you looking at like what do you want
you're actually using the voice box as a
proxy for how tough the other guy is and
yours as well so you'll hear that men
will lower their voice when they do that
number three the closing of distance
possible chest bumping and this is when
the arms extend as well so what you're
doing with the arms extending and you
see this in UFC fighters right they'll
do that when they stand on the scales
they're trying to make themselves look
as big as possible dogs do this the
hackles get raised uh like all animals
try and make their physical size as big
as possible if they're trying to um stop
confrontation and what's actually
interesting that's happening here is at
each step you're trying to avoid
confrontation you're not trying to get
to the stage where you actually do have
something physical occur
humans are 100 times or they're one
percent as aggressive as chimps but they
have the same level of death lethality
so it's a hundred times more lethal and
happens a hundred times less frequently
the reason being that the ability of
humans to be able to kill each other was
enabled by tools and weapons and like
that means that you need to be very very
careful you need if you want to go you
need to go whereas it seems like chimps
much more aggressive but they're not
going to they're not going to do as much
damage so you've got they're closing of
distance chest bump arms again like
that's just feeling them out especially
for you to do a push like that finger
poker two-handed push to the chest
number four like that again like does
this person really want to go like I
need to feel that power I need to feel
how big down at any stage here someone
could step in someone could try and sort
of de-escalate the situation what you're
also doing is you're allowing other
people to get in and maybe separate you
guys so that neither of you show a lose
face and then finally a dominant
dominant hand roundhouse punch if the
person is uh untrained in combat so
that's the sequence that you see but
when you watch it you see guys they'll
Circle each other like why are you
circling each other well that's what
stag deer do as well like stag Dias
Circle each other don't you're going to
size each other up they're going to like
move from left to right that's [ __ ]
interesting another thing that I learned
recently which I thought was absolutely
fascinating is that there's unspoken
rules in a no rules fight so for
instance if you see a street fight
first off the opponents are always going
to be usually males of a similar size
and a similar age and a similar
competence it makes no sense for a man
of 35 years old to try and fight a 12
year old or a 70 year old right the
reason that you have a fight is in order
to determine who is the most physically
dominant between two people where the
answer isn't already obvious right so we
need the fight in order to be able to
judge what's going on here so you'd
think okay
we need a reliable test of whether me or
you are tougher in a street fight so
what that means is that we need to play
by the same rules because if you play by
a set of rules that's different to mine
that makes the uh outcome of the contest
neutralize it it's no longer a reliable
sense of whether or not one is tougher
than the other so I gouging uh like
grind shots biting
um usually kicking when someone's on the
floor all of this even in a no rules
street fight would usually be frowned
upon and especially if someone was to
pull a weapon out if you're having a
fist fight and then someone pulls out a
knife or better off now this is no
longer a reliable test of whether or not
one person's uh tougher than the other
and the fascinating thing is this gets
reflected in movies so think about uh
the bond Supremacy or the bond ultimatum
every single film Jason Bourne goes into
some apartment in Paris and there's some
bastard in a black balaclava waiting for
him and they'll start with the fist
fight right so fair contest two men
equal sort of size equal sort of
competence and usually Jason will hit
him and smash him through a table or
whatever then the guy will pull out a
weapon but Jason doesn't have a weapon
okay so what we see here is that the
opponent has escalated and Jason now
somehow needs to use a less effective
tool in order to be able to eat even the
stakes so he'll get like in one of them
he kills a guy with a Biro and another
one he uses a book sort of punches this
book into his chest or into his neck or
something so again with that you even
written into movies we have this
inherent understanding that there are
rules that people are supposed to follow
and that when someone breaks them that
kind of opens up another level and
almost always the guy falls out of a
window after Jason like hits him with
the book or something and then he falls
to his death
um but yeah watching
the aggression of guys watching uh
mating Dynamics generally like who goes
for Who and the chatter procedure and
then learning about the anticipation
effect like those were three pretty big
learnings what are some of the other
Unwritten rules that you see especially
like around mating so the fighting I
think you just nailed it right in terms
of uh I think everyone who's seen a
fight happen whether it's at a nightclub
or somewhere else can say yep I saw this
this and this and like that's pretty
much how they go I also think it's
interesting that young boys uh when they
fight which many of them do almost all
of them do at some point in their life
uh they are almost reinforce certain
social norms like don't kick that guy in
the dick right is like a uh a thing that
you know that you can do but there's
almost like a gentleman's uh agreement
that like if we're gonna fist fight like
that's off limits so this kind of
Unwritten rule when it comes to The
Nightlife and mating what are some of
the rules there or Unwritten rules that
like every single person that runs a
nightlife uh venues like yep I know this
happens but like the average amateur eye
may not actually realize what's going on
so girls that walk into nightclubs with
jackets around their shoulders but not
their arms and their sleeves almost
always get kicked out within 30 minutes
that's got nothing to do with mating
that's just like a [ __ ] effect that
I've noticed you see a girl walk in all
of the door's staff will go she's gonna
get kicked out soon and sure enough she
does I don't know what it is there's
just something girls stop stop putting
your hands not in the sleeves of your
jacket because it causes you get into
fights or whatever like a half an hour
later
um when it comes to mating in nightclubs
particularly it's kind of just like a
rough hewn thing because alcohol is
involved it can be quite like
serendipitous if you're at the right
place at the right time there's a famous
show the in-betweeners in the UK and um
they're talking to each other I know
actually this is American Pie where they
say you know you see those movies and in
them like drunk girls make mistakes with
guys we could be those guys like that I
think is what a lot of uh copulation and
and the dating that occurs in Nightlife
comes from but
certainly some of the interesting stuff
I've learned recently that kind of
relates to that and also relates to the
male monkey dance
there was a study done where they got uh
videos of men they showed videos of men
to both women and to men they asked the
women how sexually attracted they were
to the guys they asked the men How
likely they thought that man was to win
a fight with another man
18 months later they came back to the
guys that were in the videos and they
looked at how many sexual partners
they'd had over the last 18 months the
girl's sexual attractiveness ratings had
zero correlation
the men's judgments of formidability
were both strong and significant in
terms of predicting the number of sexual
partners interesting so men and their
understanding of formidability is a
better predictor of mating success than
female sexual attraction at least
self-rated female sexual attraction
right there's a difference between
stated and revealed preferences like it
might be that they don't want to say
that they're actually attracted to this
guy that whatever it might be
um but that's and that's been replicated
a ton what it suggests is that women
pick off the top of a competing
hierarchy of men they just let men fight
it out between Mrs Peterson's thing
right you just let men work out the
hierarchy between them and then you just
take the top filtering from that we were
talking earlier on like before we
started about some high performing
friends and stuff the guys that you know
that are high performing women will just
let let men do what they need to do and
then they'll go okay he's the guy that
won like women to have no interest in
sport will be attracted to the best
player on the team you don't even know
the rules of the game you literally have
no idea what the rule you you don't know
how to trade you don't know how to
[ __ ] here's a good one guys that are
great at Esports like dudes did a
fantastic at gaming do you even play
does the girl even play this game
probably not but she knows that that
guy's the best and if he's the best
that's the one that I want how much of
that is uh women are attracted to men
and maybe even men are attracted to
women who are just excellent at
something right so it ends up being
um the FTX blow up recently happened and
uh there is a Tumblr for uh the CEO uh
the woman who is CEO of the hedge fund
and in it I guess she had a list of like
here's all the things that I find
attractive in men and one of them was
like uh control multiple World
governments or like like like something
that was just like wait what right uh
okay sure uh but like to me that's like
a a measure of Excellence I guess yes
like how much of it is just literally it
doesn't even matter what the thing is
whether it's physical it's intellectual
it's a spiritual or whatever it's just
like if you're excellent that is
attractive to somebody yes so I'm not
sure about this in the data but you know
anecdotally people like to admire their
Partners you don't want to pity your
partner right like if you've got someone
that's competent at something if your
message is really good at what she does
it's [ __ ] cool it's kind of sexy but
she's good at her thing like you don't
want to be better at your thing than you
are but you wanted to have her own thing
and they're definitely for men
absolutely for men that there's just
there's something
attractive about being an admirable
person about having traits and being
someone that others look up to you have
to remember as well you've got this sort
of pre-selection thing that if other
people look up to you that makes it
easier for you to choose that partner
because you go well everybody else is
looking toward this particular person
they're the ones that are the best why
don't I follow that so yeah I think that
you're right that competence is
something generally that's like
attractive and uh and admirable and
works well to improve make value what
about safety right so we talked earlier
about if there's a fist fight between
two men they try to look as big as they
possibly can there's almost this like
testing and formidability uh um like
probing that's going on right uh how
does mating and that fit into it is it
uh if you see a guy go and knock another
guy out I'm assuming most people would
come to the conclusion like oh women are
going to say oh that guy is attractive
that is somebody that I want to go talk
to or whatever but uh what about the
perception so there is no fight there is
no ability to actually get a uh kind of
objective answer as to who would win in
that fight is it just whoever's
perceived to provide the most safety or
is there some other way to look at it
yeah so
this is looking at the evolutionary
psychology stuff that I've been kind of
obsessed by recently um it seems like
fundamentally women want guys that are
protectors and providers right so you
need to be someone that is useful if the
world comes to an end and can either
outrun out fight or outpay the people
that are in the room right like that's a
good way to look at it so yeah I think
if you were to ask most women would you
rather be with a guy that makes you feel
safe or with a guy that makes you feel
unsafe a guy that can protect you or a
guy that can't protect you most of them
are going to go for the one that can
protect them if you were to ask guys the
same question about women I don't think
that that's going to matter so much
because fundamentally women on average
don't tend to be able to provide as much
protection so yeah I think that there's
a safety element there there's a
pre-selection that dominance is
something that's very that seems to be
very attractive in women uh dude I
learned some [ __ ] fascinating stuff
about women's ovulatory Cycles okay the
way that their behavior changes it's
[ __ ] wild so
when women are in the first half of
their cycle they're fertile they can get
pregnant during that time they have a
preference for masculinized faces they
have a preference for men's t-shirts
that are higher in testosterone so if a
man that's higher testosterone and lower
testosterone and she gets to smell both
of them she'll prefer the one that's
high tea now you get toward the back end
of the cycle and women prefer men who
have got more feminized faces they
prefer men that are lower in
testosterone the interesting thing is
now because of hormonal birth control
being so widely used
women are naturally suppressing their
cycles and they're stuck in that second
half so women at the moment are over
selecting for more feminized men for low
testosterone men and this means that
we're [ __ ] it's not it's not it's not
great for a certain cohort of of guys
out there it was a society though well
no because you're selecting for men
previously who wouldn't have been the
ones that would have been mated with now
there's an interesting question to ask
about should you
should you use the old rules of high
dominance high testosterone as being the
preference criteria for women to now
mate with given that we have a secure
world that doesn't need that anymore
like that's an interesting question to
ask but what definitely seems to be the
case is women who choose their Partners
when they're on birth control report
lower levels of sexual satisfaction with
them when they come off and this is like
the Golden Rule if you're in a
relationship if you're a girl or a guy
and you're on birth control you need to
come off before you decide to get
married move in together do all of that
sort of stuff because a lot of the time
women's hormonal profile changes so much
that they find out that when they come
off birth control they're just not that
attracted to their Partners anymore so
uh I was at dinner with my wife and a
couple of other couples and the woman
who sat next to my wife was a I want to
say sexual psychologist maybe she said
um and it was one of those things where
like you don't really think those people
exist until they tell you that's what
they do and so uh she also happened to
be very forthcoming and and constantly
just like interjecting into the
conversation all these uh things that
she understood so like we were learning
a lot which was interesting but also at
the same time we're like we're trying to
have a conversation like it's not all
about the the sexual psychology of it
and she said this and it blew my mind
because she was basically explaining not
in such an eloquent way but she was
explaining that like
they're in her mind was a very uh High
correlation or at least some Connection
in some way that could be measured
between uh the rise of birth control and
the increase in divorce rate and what
she was trying to explain was like the
later you get in your life the less you
may actually be using the birth control
and therefore that could be driving the
higher divorce because actually your
preferences have changed and it
fascinated me I was like I'd never even
thought about that but it seems like the
science is starting to catch up to that
and so you're saying hey maybe the woman
should come off of birth control as a
hey I really want to make sure that I'm
attracted to this person but is there
actually an argument that like if you
want to make a good selection of uh a
husband if you're a woman that being on
birth control could like deter that or
like somehow muddy the waters and like
you're increasing the odds of making a
false positive Choice yeah for sure I
mean if there is a risk that when you
come off birth control you're going to
be more dissatisfied with your partner
into that is due does not be on birth
control but obviously that's you're sort
of rolling the dice a little bit there
unless you want to be completely
celibate as a woman and then you've got
other like other types of uh protection
which you know those also have they're
not completely perfectly secure so and
and just real quick I think there's also
this part of like what is someone
optimizing for like from a male
standpoint or a female standpoint like
what is what are you optimizing for a
lot of times like people will come to me
and they'll like oh I'm in this
situation you know what do I do and one
of my questions is just like what are
you optimizing what do you want right
like yeah and if you can determine what
you want there's a lot of people who say
like I don't want to get pregnant right
or I don't want this or I do want X or Y
and so if you understand that then you
probably can actually structure your
life and what you're doing on a
day-to-day basis to pursue what you want
which therefore then will drive outcomes
that you may or may not uh intend this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
held healthier be more arrested and have
more energy throughout the day and on
the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep the problem is that most
women and guys don't know the side
effects that come with hormonal birth
control like they'll know how it makes
them feel most girls say that they sort
of dampens down the sex drive that it
makes them feel both like Pleasure and
Pain happiness and sadness less uh
richly
um and it's just a bundle that makes
them more tired makes them gain weight
makes them more hungry make a bunch of
other stuff right that second half of
the cycle stuff
um but the psychological things I I
don't think that many people have known
about the research is Dr Sarah Hill if
anyone's listening and they like the
sound of this your brain on birth
control or I've actually got an episode
which will be out by the time that
people are listening to this so they can
go and check that out on Modern wisdom
it's Dr Sarah Hill and um
the issue that you have is if women
aren't fully aware of the psychological
side effects of being on birth control
then not making it would be like you
making some sort of call with regards to
investment without knowing all of the
information to do with the market or the
company you were investing in and you go
well if I knew more would I have made a
different call well yeah but you didn't
so it's important that you educate uh
women around this and yeah for sure the
issue that you have with regards to
divorce medium term longer term
absolutely could be due to women staying
on birth control maybe even staying on
it through the wedding as well okay now
let's finally have kids you do decide to
come off in order to have children and
attraction drops because
how would the world change if men had to
take birth control and men had to be the
ones giving birth
so we keep men and women biologically in
in terms of like testosterone levels
estrogen psychology like all these
components but in mythical land not
possible but in mythical land we just
said okay now the responsibility is for
the man to remember to take birth
control the responsibility is that the
man's psychologically going to be
impacted by doing this to prevent
pregnancy uh the uh my wife and I have
talked about like I don't think there
would be as many babies if men had to
get pregnant
it would be [ __ ] pale but I'm not
[ __ ] that dude I mean there's an
interesting question around like why
isn't there a male uh birth control pill
and that's the reverse of what you're
asking if it was on men to take that
birth control the magic pill whatever
whatever it is that stops women from
getting pregnant the woman is putting
her future in the hands of a man saying
yeah don't worry honey like I took it
this morning at least if a woman misses
her own pill she knows that it was
within her control but if the man misses
it and she gets pregnant she's still
Bears all of the costs while he's the
one that said that he was doing the
thing if men were the ones that got
pregnant the world would be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show why because men aren't
predisposed to be as patient as
conscientious as nurturing as loving as
caring they don't have the same profile
that is needed in order to be able to
raise children in that way they're an
important person to have around the
house but any fi I mean you know you're
it's first birthday of one of yours
today yes
would you say that it's right that
within the first couple of years you're
kind of more like an observer when it
comes to raising children there are
certain parts for sure where the extreme
example is like the baby is crying at
night it's six months old and no matter
what you try to do for that baby that
baby you don't give a [ __ ] about you it
wants her mom and she's like where is
Mom and so you can go you can have the
greatest voice and sing you can uh try
all kinds of different positions you can
do whatever you want you could be in the
circus the baby wants the mom and uh I'm
assuming that most of that is just
biological just you know human instinct
and saying where's my mom my mom has
safety my mom has food my mom has like
all these things
um and so it then brings into the
question like well what happens for the
babies who unfortunately don't have the
mom in the first year the first five
years or whatever uh and then what is
the Divergence of path right like one of
the things um I've talked about on the
podcast before is uh there was a study
done where uh kids of families that are
considered more affluent they hear more
words and it's something on the order of
magnitude I think it was like uh either
3 million or 30 million I can't remember
exactly but like millions of more words
are spoken to them before they get to
kindergarten then kids who are from
families that are not affluent and so
what you can see is already there's like
this compounding effect well we know
that hearing more words and more
language helps you to develop your brain
faster and you become more advanced so
now all of a sudden you start to Overlay
affluence with the development of a
child simply because the parents either
have time or they care or they whatever
to speak to the child more than if they
didn't qualify for as high of an
affluence level it's fascinating well
remember as well that affluence and
income is probably going to be
correlated with a bunch of heritable
traits like maybe IQ uh maybe spatial
awareness maybe memory and reasoning
maybe conscientiousness orderliness
stuff like that so yeah you do get this
um what's called a Matthew principle
okay from the Bible uh from those who
have everything more will be given from
those who have nothing more will be
taken and this is how you end up with uh
The Haves and the have-nots right
um and yeah the the stuff when you're
looking at um child rearing is [ __ ]
terrifying there's some behavioral
genetic stuff which I've been uh into
into for a little while book called
blueprint by Robert Plowman who's
probably the world's number one
behavioral geneticist and uh I'm gonna
play a little game with you all right
okay so I'm so terrified I'm going to
ask you how heritable you think
different different traits are okay
amongst people in terms of a percentage
so 100 would be you are like it's 100
heritable zero percent is there is no
correlation between your parents and you
okay okay eye color eye color uh
probably low
heritability yes 95
and now you have me thinking like what
does he think I'm gonna say so I can say
the other okay all right good height
height
uh probably pretty high 80 okay wait
wait uh also pretty high 70 70
schizophrenia
ooh
I don't know maybe it is like uh one of
two one of three like things okay autism
autism uh probably lower 70 wow it's
much higher okay School achievement
School achievement oh I would actually
think that's probably most people think
it's low but I think it's probably
higher 60 okay verbal ability 60
remembering face is 60 spatial ability
like navigation 70 general intelligence
like reasoning 50 and personality 40 so
basically this discount what about just
pure IQ 0.8 by the end of life eighty
percent so all of the school all of the
nutrition all of the studying all of the
time spent listening to [ __ ] podcasts
and having a an ebbing house forgetting
curve space repetition program to help
you remember your notes and your Anki
playlist all of that is worth 20 like
the single best thing that you could do
for your kids if you want to improve
their outcomes in life is choose the
person that you have them with very
carefully that's the most important
thing now the problem is this gets
perilously close to Eugenics right but
everybody's committing Eugenics when
they choose one partner over another
like why is it that you like your wife
and don't like another wife like well
it's because there are certain cues that
she has given you that you interpret
quite rightly is like Beauty and Poise
and Grace and kindness and all of these
things but like when you actually boil
those down they're Fitness cues like the
cues that I have fantastic genetics the
uh sons and daughters that we would have
together would be of high genetic
quality like that is what you're talking
about so when it comes to the
heritability fact like
it's really uncomfortable to hear that
all that you're doing everything that
you're doing with regards to your like
let's say spatial reasoning which I
think was 50 or something like all of
the work that you do on that fighter
pilots and stuff like basically
everybody that's good at most of the
things that they do had a huge
predisposition when it came to it like
it would be very very hard for you to
have
to not have the genes for like
conscientiousness which is the
hard-working go-getter thing and for you
to be a pro athlete like almost all pro
athletes are probably going to be in
like the 90th percentile or something
for conscientiousness and um
this is difficult in a meritocracy right
because you're supposed to own your own
successes and also if you on your
successes than the people who have
failures own their failures
during uh ancient Greece the word that
they referred to the Beggars on the
streets as was unfortunate they were
called the unfortunates because the lady
Fortuna hadn't blessed them right and I
think Fortuna was the the god that had
um the the scales and the reason for
that was that with one hand she gives
but with the other hand she takes away
uh roll the clock forward now and what
do we call the people that don't succeed
and lay about on the couch they're
losers so we've gone from a situation
where Fortune was something that was
bestowed on all of us and taken away
from all of us to now something where
people are the owners and The Architects
of their own failures but when you look
at some of the stuff from behavioral
genetics or you know an affluent family
to a non-afluent family how is 50
million fewer words you arrive at
kindergarten at three years old four
years old you're on the back foot yeah
you can outwork that but again you I I
think it's I think it's unrealistic to
claim that people have the an even
playing field when they come in so take
something like Eugenics which
um
it feels like we understand much more
about genetics today than we did five
years ago ten years ago is definitely 20
30 40 50 years ago
it also feels like it's a topic that
when people discuss eugenics in general
but also uh more specifically certain
types of genetic traits uh things like
IQ and how correlated it is uh to who
your parents are or whatever uh there is
a moral argument there's an Ethics
argument that gets made that immediately
is like that's off limits
when you go back in history a lot of
different things that at the time had
moral ethic kind of uh antithetical
views or or kind of were put in a
category in society as taboo today we
accept this fact and one of the craziest
ones like the Earth is flat versus the
Earth is round like there literally was
uh people who were like you are an idiot
there are people who were killed for
believing this now that's not
necessarily a moral ethic thing
explicitly but like now literally there
you know there's a professional
basketball player who said the Earth is
flat and people ridiculed them and
they're like you're an idiot they didn't
kill them but they were like you're an
idiot they had like a basically like a a
public shaming you said that Kyrie
Irving unknown whether he was being
serious or not he went to Duke uh and so
people people I'm a Duke fan so it's
like hey man come on I'm like uh well I
I it's unclear whether he was trying to
antagonize people and kind of you know
poke them a little bit and just see how
dumb they thought he really was or or he
really believes it either way he was
ridiculed for it and so you go over a
couple of centuries like little really
we will kill you for believing this to
like now we will shame you for believing
the thing that used to be accepted fact
fascinating because that is I don't know
three four hundred five hundred years
when you look at genetics today it's
like On The Fringe and we're just now
starting to understand some of this
stuff like when you read this out like
you literally asked me about eye color
and I think you're trying to ask me a
trick question right and and it's like
hold on a second like we don't even know
enough about this and I'm not even
confident enough in the science to know
where are some of these traits yeah
a hundred years 200 years from now are
they going to look back at us and be
like these idiots
knew certain traits or or certain
diseases certain propensities and they
did nothing about it which again I
understand every single argument against
the whole Eugenics thing and everything
and and I'm sympathetic to many of them
and believe that uh it is probably one
of the scariest like most uh a lack of
understanding around like what would the
ramifications be what are the ethics
like I don't know I'm a complete [ __ ]
when it comes to the the nuances of it
and there's experts that are better at
it than me
but it does feel like something where
we're starting to learn enough and if
you follow kind of that direction of
progress 200 years from now before
you're born they're gonna know
everything yeah
yeah and if they make decisions on it
based on today's ethical and kind of
societal framework will it violate it I
don't know it's like a fascinating
question looking at judging the actions
of Tomorrow by the standards of today or
the actions of today by the standards of
Tomorrow are like really terrifying
things this is how someone like Kevin
Hart can have a tweet brought up from
10 years ago where he uses a word which
back then nobody picked up on but now is
completely unstable right like and
that's only 10 years yes precisely um I
think with crispr with genetic
engineering you're going to see I mean
we've already had that guy in China who
uh engineered those two twins to be more
resilient I think to HIV turns out there
was a third one wasn't just two there
was a third sister as a part of those
girls like obviously the CCP just great
with transparency and
long term I don't know
what what that's going to look like but
what you see a lot of science doing
especially when it comes to stuff that
humans do naturally is science tries to
reinvent and re-explain what humans
intuitively have already been able to do
so let me explain um I throw a ball to
you right over here that is going
whatever it is like 3.4 meters per
second squared down in a parabolic line
and this is the velocity and all the
rest of it they've just about managed to
be able to make robots that can move a
bucket to catch the ball when you throw
the ball at it if I threw a ball at a
three-year-old it would be not far off
being able to move the hand around to be
able to catch it it's like hang on a
second so humans have something inbuilt
in them which allows them to understand
how gravity works so that they can catch
the ball appropriately right it also
means that they can throw they can judge
distances they can judge depth all this
[ __ ] and we're just about trying to
re-engineer that into code so that that
can actually be be done outside of the
human system when it comes to looking at
uh genetic traits again the same thing
why is is it that
um
you are attracted to what you're
attracted to symmetrical faces for
example symmetrical faces are more
difficult to grow as a human than
unsymmetrical phases which is why we are
attracted to symmetrical faces because
they suggest stronger genetics if there
are fewer breaks in the genetic code are
kind of a little bit over my skis here
but if the genetic makeup of the person
has fewer errors in it you end up with a
more symmetrical face is what I
understand so if that's the case
and when you look at someone that is
more symmetrical versus less symmetrical
and you choose the more symmetrical one
are you doing genetic Eugenics is that
Eugenics there well kind of any make
preferences uh the waist to hip ratio
that women have that's a fertility cue
women that have high waist to hip ratios
seem on average to be more fertile to
have more children
okay so if you choose to go with The
Hourglass physique over the girl with
the non-hourglass physique that's
Eugenics and you know that mate
selection is that now the problem is
when you take this and you use it to
justify awful [ __ ] policies right
when you start to talk about superiority
when you start to talk about differences
in group IQ to justify different things
like that that's when you're going too
far but understanding the way that
genetics influences what goes what like
Huntington's disease if two partners if
sorry if one partner has Huntington's
disease and the other partner also has
that Gene like the kids getting
Huntington's disease I'm I don't know if
it's even Elite is it illegal for two
people with Huntington's to to marry and
have kids very well I might be right
like [ __ ] why a brother and sister
not allowed to marry and have kids like
for the exact same reason they do in
some states
just kidding just kidding just kidding
dude I'm from Texas just kidding um no
but but I think what you're highlighting
here is like we are much more
comfortable uh with implicit uh kind of
aspect of it when it becomes explicit
when it is uh called out and people then
say because of X I am going to do y
it's uncomfortable
all right and like I think even if you
were to interview people who were like
there's no problem with this like we
should do it and you start asking them a
lot of like super nuanced questions they
get in like some pretty gray area pretty
quickly to the point where people are
like ah this makes me feel uncomfortable
dude if you if you stress test most of
the people that have got pretty nasty
ideas hard
they end up falling to pieces quite
quickly because
a lot of the and this is the problem
with behavioral genetics with
evolutionary psychology as well it can
be weaponized by some pretty nasty
groups in in order to justify some
pretty [ __ ] heinous things and that
that's something that you can really
only watch out for if you know what to
watch out for like putting your head in
the sand doesn't really work but dude I
mean rolling the clock forward and
thinking about
um what's going to happen with genetic
engineering I was talking to this guy
who's trying to re-engineer human DNA to
be able to survive space flight it's one
of the problems that we've got is that
there's tons of [ __ ] radiation as
soon as you get outside of the
atmosphere and then
um is it the Kuiper belt what's the
thing that protects the solar system
there's something else that protects the
solar system against solar wind once you
get outside of that it's just radiation
all day so the human DNA is going to
break down so this guy is trying to
re-engineer human DNA to be uh more
resistant to a bunch of these other
things you want to talk about an
interesting ethical question
let's say that you can go on a
Generation ship that you and future
Generations will live on in order for us
to get to the closest habitable planet
that we can find but by you saying yes
to going on it
you commit
your kids or your grandkids 10 future
Generations or 20 future generations for
the next half Millennia uh for being on
there as well like is that a choice that
you get to make
it gets into
um long-termism I don't know if you've
looked at this William mccaskill all
these guys um I I recently was reading
uh the book yes and um
he started to outlay uh how many people
have lived versus how many could live in
the future
dude we don't [ __ ] matter
like you start looking at it and at one
point he's like you know uh okay he has
like these 10 um I I think I'm gonna
remember this correctly but he's got
like 10 uh kind of uh human figures
right and he's like each one of these 10
is basically uh a billion people he's
like okay now I'm gonna take that same
figure and I'm gonna colored in Black
now it's 10 billion people and he goes
if the world lasts for whatever 500
million years or what whatever it is
he's like this is how many people are
still yet to live in the future and he
fills the whole first page the whole
second page the whole third page and
about half of the fourth page and he
goes by the way I'm just gonna stop now
but I could have filled 20 000 books
with these black little figures because
that's how many people we have yet to go
I hope that like me stopping the diagram
gets the point on the illustrative yeah
yeah yes and so his argument and kind of
this whole argument of long-termism is
basically the decisions we make today do
have an impact in the future and if we
take it seriously like uh although we
may not meet them we should care what
world they live in ETC you're
extrapolating even further you're saying
no no it's not just about like unearth
it's like you may make a decision today
like go on to a generational spaceship
that will take your entire family
lineage on a on a Intergalactic Journey
that they may not be excited about yep
yeah and are you
considering the ethical ramifications is
there legal ramifications uh how about
the grandparents how about the uncles
and aunts that may not be able to
interact with those people like
condemning people to be born live and
die like that's your whole life you're
never going to touch Earth and this is
going to be something that we're going
to have to come up against unless we can
Wormhole our way or faster than the
light travel our way and it seems very
likely that we're going to get to
um interplanetary travel with sufficient
protection in order to be able to make
generation ships viable before we manage
to get to faster than light travel so
this is a genuine question that's going
to have to be asked
is it ethical in order to condemn
20 future generations of your progeny to
being born living and dying on a [ __ ]
in a tin box in the sky is it depressing
that we're unlikely to live to see the
interplanetary uh craziness like in some
way we're too late for the Roman Empire
and we're too early for the like
Intergalactic Empire we just got
dopamine hijacked from [ __ ] Tick Tock
yeah yeah but what's the defining what's
the defining characteristic of this
generation and it it I really really
hope that it isn't
um in 200 years that future humans look
back and see what we're doing now and go
can you believe what they were doing to
attention and media and communication uh
and interpersonal love and social
cohesion with that technology and they
had these weird devices and they held
them in their hands and they input it
with their thumbs like
that is it wouldn't surprise me if that
was the case
um what would be even more scary is if
we still haven't transcended that in 200
years time but something tells me that
we will yeah I think there's always a
question of like
would it be better to have been born
later given that progress seems to be on
average linearly improving uh would it
be better to be born later maybe but the
chance of you existing is so
infinitesimally small like the only way
that you can be here with your precise
genetic makeup which is what makes that
Consciousness that's inside of you
is if there was a complete unbroken
lineage from the very first
single-celled organism all the way
through everything and it couldn't have
been a different sperm it couldn't have
been a different egg it had to be your
grandparents it had to be at that time
at that time of the month with that
particular
every single one of them all the way
this unbroken chain that leads up to you
so yes if you were to look forward and
say how unfortunate is it that I'm not
there to see the future that sucks but
the fact that you're here at all is
something I think that you should take a
lot of solace in
as we look forward there's Evolution
there is what we know today
psychological development all of that we
are going to introduce technology we
already have to some degree
um and I think about offense and
defensive forces so offensive Force
could be uh we're going to put a brain
uh computer interface we're going to
insert it into your brain you now have
computational power oh my ancestors were
morons they had phones I just think and
[ __ ] happens right okay that feels very
much offensive uh in general yes there
are things around disease or or
disabilities that that it'll impact but
mostly that's an offensive technology
defensive changes is something where it
kind of just happens almost like more
passive maybe it's a better word to
describe text neck is future Generations
all going to be hunched over you know
because we're all hunched over our
phones right and so you know our
grandkids grandkids grandkids are just
like God damn it you know three five
twenty Generations ago they literally
had these phones they were hunched over
and now look at me so I got born with a
straight okay you're suggesting that
because we're using a phone so much it
would be advantageous to have long
thumbs so in like 100 Generations we're
gonna have long thumbed children your
eyes are bigger you're hunched over you
have longer like there's all these
little things and so some of it is like
maybe like uh uh offensive and um
explicit it is external right kind of uh
um uh optimizations and and uh trying to
improve the human experience with
technology from the outside some of it
there was this passive stuff and so as
Evolution and psychology because you're
also [ __ ] with your brain right uh on
Tick Tock or whatever all day
um when we extrapolate this out are
humans going to be better humans or
Worse humans
200 400 500 years from now like if we go
back and we celebratize you know I don't
know uh the ancient warriors or uh the
Apache Indians like you know they were
these war-like uh uh figures they had uh
very simple lives the stoics had this
clear way of thinking like sure that
wasn't 100 of the population but there
are these examples of people who I think
we aspire to be like or we adhere to 500
years from now is The Human Experience
going to be better or worse
I think the Human Experience will
probably be better okay
um I think one of the advantages you
have of evolution is it works so slowly
that it's really [ __ ] hard to mess up
it's really difficult to lock in bad
evolutionary change into a species
especially like humans that takes 25
years to go through a generation in you
know 10 Generations nothing's changed
and here's the interesting thing if your
environment is changing unbelievably
quickly any of the adaptations that you
would have found during generation one
that were advantageous would have been
the situation is so different during
generation 10 that that change is now no
longer useful so all of this just comes
out in the wash does that make sense
that like let's say that now it's thumbs
we want long thumb children but in five
generations time it's in your brain okay
well the thumbs things now pointless and
so is the next thing and so is the
posture thing now what does change much
more quickly and I think what you're
referring to is culture it's like what
is it that we can uphold as values that
we care about what are the sort of
things that we should praise in people
should we have resiliency grit
determination Community those are the
sorts of things that we look back to and
feel are missing I think from the world
now and yeah the more that you Outsource
this
the uh rule making rule breaking rule
enforcement support systems to
any kind of superstructure whether that
be
um the bricks and mortars that are
around us that are protecting us from
the weather outside whether that's the
air con that's keeping us cool whether
that's the police that keep us safe
whether that's the internet that keeps
us smart right or Wikipedia that keeps
us informed like whatever it is as soon
as you start to Outsource something
you'll atrophy whatever the muscle was
whether that be cultural psychological
physical that was previously supporting
that system to work you know what I mean
as we go down that path one of the
questions then becomes like why are we
here
and yes there's this evolutionary Arc
there's a psychological one as well
um but the belief of why we're here
seems to evolve as well and if you go
back uh I don't know uh use Ancient Rome
as a good example if you were to ask
people why are you here why are you
human what is it to mean to be human
we I think in one way in society we say
hey that answer hasn't changed because
if you look at the Stokes we're gonna be
like oh for thousands of years like
people who knew this stuff whatever on
the other hand like it feels like
there's way more people who are more
ambitious or Bolder right and the way
that I almost think of this is like if
you go back to ancient Rome how many
people thought that they could like
conquer the Earth maybe that was like
the most ambitious thing like definitely
some they tried right and so that was
happening today if you said how many
people think that they can solve some
incredibly hard problem that would have
a material impact on a billion people or
something like there are many more
people who think they can do that today
than the amount of people who thought
they could conquer the world was like a
billion people back then and so is that
had a changing of like what people think
is possible is that a changing of what
they think it means to be human is that
just a changing of like arrogance level
like there's a lot of things that go
into this
but if that keeps multiplying eventually
you're going to have like one in ten
people who have some crazy ambitious you
know thing and that feels like something
that doesn't really fit into the
evolutionary bucket it doesn't really
fit into psychology like it's maybe
culture like it's kind of everything
wrapped up together I don't know what do
you think yeah I mean Leverage is a hell
of a drug right the ability to leverage
your inputs into greater I mean this is
the industry that you come from is the
industry of Leverage right
um
definitely as Humanity's capabilities
increase what you end up with are
greater and greater goals goal sizes
that people go for so for instance I
don't think anybody would have looked at
the Romans and said that it was their
job to protect species and ensure that
the future of humanity was safe right
the wisdom was ahead of the
technological capability the problem
that we have now is that our
technological capability has overtaken
our wisdom we have the ability to
release viruses and cause damage uh
interesting point uh it doesn't look
like nuclear war would be an existential
threat it would kill tons of people it
would not be good it would be a bad day
if all the nukes went off bad day but it
wouldn't be the end of humanity and that
is a a very good position to be in
I think that there is a good argument to
be made that right now the job of
humanity is to ensure the future of
humanity because we are at a stage the
precipice Toby odd calls it this
particular point in time where we have a
very narrow path that we're walking
along and if we get through it hopefully
technological capability and wisdom
should be so great that any challenges
we encounter should be fine for us to
get past but at the moment we have an
awful lot of risks and not so many
solutions you know we just got nailed by
an illness for two years and we didn't
have we weren't able to do anything we
weren't able to make masks quickly
enough we weren't able to shut down
travel we didn't have the cultural
institutions the medical institutions we
didn't have the wisdom the communique
any of that right none of it was sorted
and that was like nothing that was
absolutely nothing compared with what
could be thrown at us whether it be a
super volcano whether it be a solar
flare from the Sun that cuts out all of
the electricity on the planet whether
it's an asteroid that's coming towards
us or another bio weapon or a natural
pandemic or you know a AGI Whatever
Whatever It Is Right some and tons of
things that could cause problems
at the moment we have the ability to
cause them but not really the ability to
protect ourselves from them and that to
me
gives me a good bit of pause that makes
me think that a lot of our efforts
should be placed on just getting through
the next few hundred years like some of
the smartest people that I know don't
think that humanity is going to make it
past 2100 like some of the smartest
people that I know think why what do
they think is the biggest threat biggest
threats AGI so artificial general
intelligence
um
they think that in the next
or less years basically the computers
will kill the humans the problem that
you have is as soon as you have
recursive self-improvement a computer
that can program itself to become a
better computer you get what's called an
intelligence explosion so the curve kind
of goes like this goes like this and
then it just it just takes off yeah
precisely in the space of a weekend
even if all you had was the same
processing power as the brain
but it was running on the components of
a computer which is significantly
quicker because the components of a
computer run at the speed of light and I
think that our brain moves way way way
slower in terms of how it communicates
uh you would come back after a weekend
and had you have left it at human brain
at the start it would have done the
equivalent of four million years of
eight phds working full time over a
weekend so you come back and you you are
now by far the dumbest thing in the room
right so if you roll the clock forward
from there you have this potential where
a
algorithm a computer system is now by
far the smartest thing it is able to
outsmart you and all of your efforts to
turn it off if it has any objectives
it's going to make sure that in order to
achieve the objective it can't be turned
off you are someone that could turn it
off you need to go away well hang on so
could the guy next to you so could that
technician so he needs to go away and
you end up with a runaway problem that
is very difficult to stop so let's say
that this intelligence explosion happens
how do you go from a threat
identification to human dead is that
clear yet it could happen in a million
different ways I think
um there's an interesting thought
experiment called the paperclip
maximizer by Nick Bostrom so
a company that makes paper clips wants
to improve the efficiency of its
pay-per-clip production
decides that it's going to create a
algorithm that can do that and buy and
load it ends up having this Superstar
coder that creates a super intelligent
algorithm to make paper clips now this
super intelligent algorithm decides that
in order for it to fulfill its one
objective which is make as many paper
clips as possible that's all it's given
single function right well it realizes
that all of the humans around it could
turn it off and if it was turned off
then it wouldn't make as many paper
clips so it decides to subdue them
somehow might kill them might do
something else but then it realizes that
it needs to be able to be powered for
all of time in order to be able to do
this so it then takes over the entire
power grid then it realizes that the
humans might wage a war on it in order
to stop it so it just kills all of the
humans but then what it realizes is is
that all of the matter that the humans
were made of
would be better as paper clips because
if the matter that the humans were
they're dead decaying bodies in the in
the earth well okay so I'll take their
matter and I'll turn that into
paperclips and the same goes for the
Earth and the Sun and the solar system
and the rest of the Galaxy and the
universe and you end up with the entire
universe of paper clips right from one
single function and
it's kind of a ridiculous example but it
shows the problem when you have what's
called misalignment so when the
objective that you give a very powerful
machine is not aligned with actually
what you wanted it to do
you end up with some very strange uh
outcomes when you scale it up to super
intelligent basically god-like creature
right
um
how it would identify stuff basically
once you get to the stage of it being
super intelligent it's game over like
you can't there's no putting it back in
the bottle and this is the AI safety uh
world and Alignment theory is is looking
particularly at trying to get out ahead
of this problem it wants there to be no
agis no super intelligent agis up until
this alignment problem's been fixed
because you can't put the toothpaste
back in the tube once it's happened how
much does the problem uh Engineers
trying to build something shiny and cool
but not understanding the negative side
effects versus actual malice like is it
ignorance or is it like some evil coder
is sitting there and like I'm gonna
build the super intelligence to take
over the world you know I think very
much the first one because the
incentives generally in the market would
support that like
the the company that makes the first
super intelligent AGI algorithm is the
world's first gazillionaire right they
they own everything they can make a
better Amazon than Amazon they can make
a better Jeff Bezos than Bezos right
they can do everything that anybody can
do better than they can do it basically
instantly and it means that anybody else
that then comes in because you have that
parabolic line anybody that's further
down the curve is so far behind that it
basically doesn't matter right the
recursive self-improvement means that
games accrue so quickly that anybody
that starts even three weeks later is
way behind and it basically doesn't
matter so
I think that
well-meaning inquisitive curious
competent coders are the most likely
potential demise of all of civilization
and that's a big concern
how do we
wrap our arms around them and say help
us you know help build a better world
not help build a world that you
accidentally ruin is there certain
things that you think are like crucial
uh to solve that problem or is it no the
people who are working on the AI safety
stuff they just got to get you know kind
of get it together and solve the
alignment problem and then we won't even
have to really deal with the uh with the
engineers because ultimately they'll
just be given a framework and and it's
kind of like bring the solution to the
masses really try to get the masses to
create the solution they'll work inside
of hopefully an existing protective
Paradigm so I don't know whether you
know the way that um tabletop genetic
synthesizes work so it's kind of like um
that was Spanish to me kind of like a
kind of like a 3D printer uh that does
it can create genetic
um like material okay so if you wanted
to sequence particular DNA it'll do it
for you and kind of like a 3D printer
you'd plug in I wanted to make a bouncy
ball or whatever and then it creates a
ball over time
um the way that all of these current
desktop printers work are that they go
up to the cloud in order to get whatever
sequence it is that you want and there
are levels of security so there's like a
green and Amber and a red the green
anybody can print it doesn't matter no
one's concerned the Amber you need to
get clearance and the red it just won't
print the reason for that is that the
stuff that's in red is [ __ ] like
smallpox and Anthrax and and stuff so
you don't and then the SWAT team comes
in and it alerts everybody and like bad
stuff happens what they've done is
they've realized there is technology
that has outstripped safety and they
need to constrain the potential
externalities of this happening and they
do that in a smart way what would be
great would be to somehow have a similar
sort of
um uh system in place for coding now
it's going to be very different and
difficult because coding's so
distributed it's so atomized like one
person could do it it's probably going
to be someone like Google deepmind I
think that comes up with this but
what would be great would be if all of
the people that are working on super
intelligent agis had AI safety as their
first priority like the problem is that
the incentives don't necessarily align
if you decide to be five percent more
safe than me and I just roll the dice
and I get there before you I win
and what you get here is just an Ever
decreasing level of safety down to no
safety again and then people just run as
fast as they say deregulation basically
so everyone wants a deregulated market
so that then it's free competition which
uh sounds great the only thing is that
there's trade-offs
uh open AI is I think a 20 billion
dollar company now
um yeah I'm pretty sure that's true uh
and it feels like they just scratched
the surface so to your point about like
whoever gets their first wins uh but
they don't just win like a market they
like win the World
um to have built a company that pretty
much just built like developer tools
right I mean again I'm highly General
generalizing in in some way uh dumbing
down what they do but uh they've built a
bunch of libraries and models that
people can go and they could use and
they can pay for and and uh already I
think it's had this explosion of
interest and developers running wild
with it or whatever but like that's a 20
billion dollar company it's not easy to
build a 20 billion dollar company uh and
it kind of feels like they're just again
just starting and so is it going to be
thousands of companies all worth
billions of dollars or is it going to be
you know kind of the centralized Amazon
has 50 of e-commerce in America and so
we're gonna have one massive AI company
that uh kind of dominates and like you
kind of can see both potentially playing
out uh
I don't know if really the dominant one
is the better world like you kind of
want it to be as stupid as possible but
again you need the safety so like it it
has this like trade-off I don't know one
of the problems that you have if it's so
distributed is that if all of these
individual actors all have the ability
to do god-like stuff you have to try and
regulate all of them if you just have
one all of the resources all of the
scrutiny everything goes on to that one
um now yeah typically monopolies and
even oligopolies aren't fantastic for
the market because you get price fixing
and you like reduce like customer
experience on the so forth
but in this I don't think you have a
choice like the the first company that
does this is the only one that's it
there is only one winner when it comes
to this
um you may end up with
on route to that a bunch of companies
that are all
90 of the way to AGI let's say and
they're all just kind of battling around
for whatever it might be to to just
push it over the edge but when the first
one goes I'm pretty sure that's just
game over game over yeah because of that
recursive thing in that parabolic line
the last thing I want to talk about uh
the podcast you've talked to many many
people I think over 500 people now
um and some of them are very different
types of people what is like maybe one
or two common themes that you see
through all of these different
conversations right you talk to everyone
from evolutionary psychologists to Jocko
to Jordan Peterson like it really is uh
pretty diverse
what are the takeaways from so many
conversations with just fellow humans
most of the people that I've spoken to
that are successful are curious
that's probably the single most common
Trend that I see
um they're LED forward by a desire to
find out about the world and that seems
to be a very robust way to motivate
yourself to go forward
um I think you can work out whether
you're having a good life because if you
wake up in the morning and you're gassed
about your day if you're excited when
you wake up
things are probably going well and these
are the people that wake up and they're
excited about what they get to learn uh
that seems to be a really really good
marker and that's something that I see
between between most of the people that
I speak to
um you know there's basic stuff like
conscientiousness hard work motivation
sticking to promises that they made to
themselves but
maybe one other thing is
um
around
success and happiness and and this isn't
for everybody but certainly in the world
of crypto and trading and business and
stuff like that I think this would
probably be a nice Insight a lot of the
time what people do when they try and
Achieve happiness through success is
that they sacrifice the thing that they
want for the thing that's supposed to
get it
they sacrifice happiness in order to get
success because success is supposed to
make them happy
you sacrifice the thing that you want
for the thing that's supposed to get it
and the older
that the guests are that I speak to
accrued a little bit more wisdom and the
more comfortable and the less that they
seem like they have to prove
the happier they seem to be and I think
that a big part of that is this success
and happiness balance that's going on
um I try and remind myself of that a lot
if I put out an episode that I thought
was amazing and it doesn't do very well
or I get criticized online or you know I
I start to um have self-doubt about my
performance or what it is that I'm doing
or whatever
um
I really tried to just remind myself
like look
you're happy with what you're doing the
success is a byproduct of that but it's
not the determinant of it like the goal
that you're working toward here is for
you to be happy with what you do
and
I think that
if you are not the sort of person who
has validation internally no amount of
external validation is going to fix that
like if you tell people what you think
they want to hear which is something I
did for a long time right I was this
club promoter standing in the front door
of nightclubs and running this great
company with my business partner that I
absolutely adore um but I was playing a
little bit of a role
um in this world because you need to
like people don't want to hear a
conversation about whether [ __ ] human
DNA can survive space flight they're on
the front door of a nightclub right they
want to hear they want to see you smile
they want to hear how many hot girls are
inside do you want a free drinks voucher
and a VIP band and they want you to [ __ ]
off right so
I became the person that I needed to for
the job that I did
um
but there's not really any amount of
success or number of friends like that
or number of acquaintances or people
that know you uh that will make you feel
fulfilled in my experience and I'm I
feel really thankful that I kind of got
a taste of what happens if you try and
climb up a very high ladder that's up
against the wrong wall super young
because coming out of that it's reminded
me okay like
it can be fun but ultimately is not as
fulfilling as trying to do something
that genuinely gives you a sense of
self-worth and uh all of the validation
in the world dude I did I did two
reality TV shows ran the biggest events
company pretty much in the north of the
UK for a decade and a half met a million
people stood on the front door of
nightclubs and still had something that
was missing but I was successful with
all of the metrics that like Society
should tell a young guy that he was
successful on like status and Accolade
and girls and like money and youth all
of this together
and he was like well
I don't know this kind of is this all it
is is this really all it is is there
nothing else to this and um
yeah no amount of external validation is
going to give you internally what it is
that you need and if you compromise
yourself
even if you don't think that you're
noticing each little white lie that you
tell each time you compromise what you
believe to tell the person that you're
speaking with what you think they want
to hear that will reflectively make you
look good every time you do that
something is keeping note uh and the
situation that I managed to get myself
to about six years ago just before I
started the show was like I didn't know
my own opinion I didn't know
anything because what I'd done was I'd
played the role that I thought people
wanted me to be for a very long time and
when it comes to all of the guests that
I've had and all of the people that I've
spoken to the ones that seem the most
fulfilled and the most happy are the
ones that are no longer concerned about
playing that role they do what they want
to do they understand who they are and
why they're here and what it is that
they're trying to achieve they have
boundaries that they won't cross they
have values that they're not going to
compromise on and that's it that's the
game
gawandi wrote a book uh being mortal and
and it uh the idea of happiness is
basically uh expectations minus reality
right and uh it's essentially what
you're highlighting here of just like if
you think that uh you have to have the
perfect life to be happy reality is that
no one has a perfect life and so like
you're basically persistently going to
be unhappy uh if you think that you need
nothing to be happy reality is better
than that and so like you will be
persistently happy
um but also he talks about uh in
somewhat of like an Ode to like the
stoics and those types of individuals
old people not not like hey I'm later in
my career like 85 95 year olds or some
of the happiest people in the world
because they no longer are focused on
the past and they no longer are focused
on the future they're just happy to be
there in that moment and so his view of
the world is like by spending so much
time with people who don't have a lot of
time it is clarifying how to spend your
life and be happy happy because what you
learn is that like all the [ __ ]
disappears and you're just enjoying the
moment and so like whether you're a
Doctor Who's used to dealing with people
and in geriatrics and kind of end of
life and like all these like very
complex things that Society doesn't like
to think about or you're the stoics who
like now are being you know put on this
pedestal
it all comes down the same thing it's
like here and now
not having high expectations but living
a fulfilled life and like you can get to
that happiness but to your point the
things that you think may make you happy
aren't really that smart to pursue if
you're going to have to sacrifice
happiness to get them yes well that's
the problem because one of the uh
instincts that a lot of the people
listening like type a go-getter people
that probably listen to this show will
feel when you say uh have lower
expectations is well no [ __ ] you I want
to be I want to be a winner like I want
to be a big hitter and you go I'm not
going to have lower expectations because
that's going to lower my performance
like let's [ __ ] face facts man a big
chunk of the people listening to this
podcast and me and you have achieved
success because of a fear of
insufficiency of course because we are
terrified of not being
wanted or needed by the world and what
we're doing is we're filling that void
with success hoping that that is somehow
going to make us feel whole again right
if you get rid of the void a lot of us
are scared that you're going to get rid
of the drive like that's the thing that
made me into the killer that I am right
whether it's time or whether it's
success if you sacrifice the thing that
you want happiness for the thing which
is supposed to get it success or time
right people make themselves miserable
by spending their time in order to be
able to do something that can finally
make themselves happy it's like if you
[ __ ] made an equation out of that and
you just removed time from both sides of
it you're left with happiness in the
middle right like
I I think that it is a very difficult
balance in order to be a high achieving
but well-balanced person and this is one
of the reasons why as people get older
they're happy with what they've achieved
which allows them to to drop that away
desire is a contract you make with
yourself to be unhappy until you get
what you want right that's Naval
I think that he is a particularly
interesting example because he's someone
that's a very high achiever but also
seems to have found a good amount of
peace with what it is that he does and I
think that that's the goal that you try
and get towards like not from a place of
insufficiency not from a place of lack
just that life is more interesting if I
achieve well and if I fulfill my
capabilities so that's why I'm going to
perform and the byproduct of that will
be happiness hopefully such a no-brainer
where can we send people to find the
podcast and maybe give them a little bit
of a understanding of the types of
guests that you have and kind of what
the the focus of the conversations are
yeah so modern wisdom uh it's on Spotify
and apple podcasts as modern wisdom and
then Chris Williamson on YouTube
episodes that I think your guys would
like Andrew huberman I had him on WE
filmed the whole thing in 6K in Austin
it's beautiful uh that was a really
really great episode some great
science-based tools for productivity for
morning cycles and and getting to bed
and supplementation and training uh Dr
Sarah Hill that was a lady that did the
hormonal birth control thing she just
blew my face stuff she was fantastic and
then I did a really great episode with
Jordan Peterson at the start of this
year so there's three huberman Sarah
Hill and Jordan Peterson and if you just
put Chris Williamson Andrew hewman in or
whatever or modern wisdom on Spotify
it'll come up uh and I appreciate you
man I've been looking forward to
speaking to you for ages it's [ __ ]
dope to finally get to meet you thank
you for having me yeah I've really
enjoyed it we'll definitely do it again
in the future